sie sagen die wärmewende die wird nicht
nur teuer für uns alle sondern eventuell
bringt die dem Klima gar nichts sondern
kann auch sogar noch schädigen ihr Thema
ja die habe ich heizungspolitik ist aus
meiner Sicht schädlich fürs Klima wir
ich habe vor ein paar Tagen Besuch in
meiner Sprechstunde in meinem Wahlkreis
gehabt und da saß ein Bürger vor mir und
der hat gesagt wissen Sie was die
Politik kann mich mal und dann schreibt
ja wie meinen sie das denn jetzt also er
lässt sich hier jetzt nicht vorschreiben
was er im Zweifel für eine Heizung
einbaut er hat eine gut funktionierende
Gasheizung die auch gut immer gepflegt
hat aber die Unsicherheit ist so groß
dass er sich in diesem Jahr eine neue
Gasheizung einbauen wird das heißt
völlig eine schizophrene Situation ich
stell mal die These auf dass wir in
diesem Jahr 2023 so viele neue Gas und
Ölheizung sehen werden wie schon seit
vielen vielen Jahren nicht mehr und
daran sieht man dieser
planwirtschaftliche Ansatz das ist genau
der falsche wir müssen eben hinzu zu
Anreizen zu der Bepreisung die wir
gerade eben besprochen haben aber dieses
Chaos was habe ich hier ausgelöst hat
ist schlichtweg schlecht fürs Klima also
nochmal konkret zu Ihnen kommen Menschen
die sagen ich baue mir jetzt obwohl
meine Gasheizung noch wunderbar
funktioniert baue ich mir jetzt schnell
noch eine neue ein weil dann kann ich
die weiter betreiben und so umgehe ich
ja die Wärmepumpe
was was vielleicht bei mir im Wahlkreis
in der Pfalz im Einzelfall ist sondern
wir sehen dass quer in Deutschland das
ist vielleicht über in Teilen überhaupt
nicht rational weil auch diese Heizung
wird vielleicht irgendwann mal kaputt
gehen und wir werden auch sehen das
Gaspreise auch natürlich in den nächsten
Jahren steigen werden aber die
Verunsicherung bei den Menschen ist ja
riesengroß kein Mensch weiß dass die
Pläne die im Januar mal vorgestellt
worden sind mit denjenigen die da heute
im Kompromiss schon da sind schwächer
sind aber dieses kommunikative Chaos das
hat einen Namen und das ist Minister
Habeck und das muss er sich einfach auch
das muss er sich auf den Hut nehmen und
deswegen finde ich schon richtig dass
man sagt also jetzt noch sieben Monate
bis zu so einer Umstellung ist einfach
zu lang wir müssen dieses Gesetz
schieben und aus meiner Sicht auch
rückabwickeln ich habe sie ein bisschen
schnaufen hören ich glaube nicht vor
Begeisterung aber glauben Sie dass die
Politik die Sorgen und Ängste der
Menschen die jetzt beispielsweise zu den
steiniger kommen und auch sagen da
geht's ja um Existenzen da geht es um
ich habe mir mein Häuschen gebaut jetzt
muss ich irgendwie schauen wie kann ich
überhaupt alles umsetzen glauben Sie
dass die Politik dass derzeit ernst
genug nimmt sie nimmt das machen im
Eindruck nach ernst aber sie hat das
völlig unterschätzt sie hat es im Angang
und das ist das sträflich jemand kann da
ja gar nicht dran vorbei reden es ist
die große Frage warum im Raum wäre ein
Interesse daran hat uns deutlich zu
sagen dass das Gesetz als Entwurf nicht
unbedingt von Robert Habeck in seinem
Entwurf Zustand an die Öffentlichkeit
geraten ist es ein offenes Geheimnis ob
es die FDP oder andere waren die gleiche
Opposition gemacht haben ist bekannt
aber in der Tat ich gebe ihn völlig
Recht und das ist dramatisch es ist aber
dramatisch für die Zustimmung dieser
Koalition dass man am Anfang das war der
Kardinalfehler nie den Eindruck erweckt
hat dass die Bevölkerung für den Schutz
der Zukunft also für das was die Zukunft
die Generation als Freiheit erhalten
müssen dass wir in der Gegenwart dafür
einen Preis zahlen müssen die Illusion
dieser wunderbaren selfie-koalition wenn
ich sozusagen darf auch in der ja meiner
Meinung auch verteilen Weise von den
Grünen in Selbstbeweihräucherung mit der
FDP als vermeintlich eine Gruppierung
zwischen die kein Blatt Papier passiert
eingegangen die Illusion bestand von
Anfang an darin das machen wir alles
Lachs und auf dem technologischen Wege
und das geht alles ohne jede Einbuße das
war das große Freiheitsversprechen wenn
ich mal so sagen darf dann kam der
russische Angriffskrieg damit war die
Übergangstechnologie des billigen Gases
Geschichte und seitdem sind wir einen
anderen Zeit und seitdem kommt noch
hinzu dass natürlich die Grünen alleine
auch weiter Flur stehen sie haben eine
Opposition in der Regierung und sie
haben das ist nicht hinweg zu reden sie
haben den Kardinalfehler gemacht dass
sie mit einem unausgegorenen sozial
nicht abgefederten Gesetz die
Bevölkerung heillos überfordert haben
heilungs und und in Ängste umgebracht
haben das Recht sich bitte das Recht
sich bitte ich bedauer natürlich
trotzdem man muss sich eines immer
bewusst machen dieser Vorgang den dieses
Ministerium habe ich an der Brust hat
nicht das so sagen darf eine
sozialökologische Transformation ein
Abschied aus der fossilistischen Moderne
leisten zu müssen weil das uns Paris
aber auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht
vorschreibt dieser Anspruch ist nach wie
vor völlig richtig aber er hat natürlich
leider jetzt
kontraproduktive folgen weil die
Bevölkerung sich zum Teil nicht
mitgenommen fühlt und das ist dramatisch
zusammenfassen
nur ein Fehler in der Kommunikation und
nicht in der Sache und die Sache ist so
schmerzhaft wie das für viele auch sein
mag man wird für den Klimaschutz leiden
müssen man wird auf Luxus verzichten
müssen und das hätte man einfach nur
deutlicher sagen müssen ich bin davon
absolut überzeugt wie gestehen dass bloß
alle nicht ein wir werden das ist doch
genau das was wir eigentlich
wahrscheinlich auch in vielen Teilen
wissen wir wollen es bloß nicht so gerne
zur Kenntnis nehmen weil es mit Einbußen
im gegenwärtigen es kennt damit zusammen
dass das was wir gegenwärtig ein Stück
weit auch für konsumieren übrigens über
20 Jahre eigentlich höchst
individualistisch immer für konsumiert
haben ob wir neue Autos gekauft haben
denken wir an die große letzte
Konjunktur Offensive hier das
zerschreddern unsere Autos
wenn wir uns erinnern die die die
Abwrackprämie wir müssen uns bewusst
machen wir werden heute eher ins
Allgemeinwohl investieren müssen diese
ganze Investition in Abdämmung ist eine
Investition in das Gemeinwohl damit die
Freiheit bzw die klimatischen
Voraussetzung für die kommenden
Generation haltbar sind das ist aber
hoch schmerzlich und es überfordert in
der Tat das kann ich auch absolut
verstehen es überfordert viele heillos
die Leute die ein kleines Haus haben die
plötzlich mit 50 000 € rechnen müssen
sind natürlich konsterniert oder sogar
mehr ich weiß ja und ist zum Teil auch
nicht können sind konsterniert den
Vorwurf muss man leider machen und das
war der kardinalfeder von Anfang an
dieser Koalition ein Stück weit Baden
dass die Grünen natürlich maximal aus
weil habe ich dieses Ministerium am
Hacken hat und natürlich und das muss
man halt sagen immer gekontert wird von
der FDP in der eigenen Koalition die
absolut Opposition zum Prinzip ihrer
koalitionsfähigkeit gemacht
ich kann mir vorstellen dass sie einige
Punkte dort ein bisschen anders darüber
gesprochen wie viel muss man eingehen
wie viel wird uns das Kosten wie
schmerzhaft wird es auch für jeden
Einzelnen ist das einfach nur ein Fehler
der Kommunikation müssen wir das einfach
auf uns nehmen jeder muss bereit sein
diese Wege auch zu gehen also mehrere
Punkte der erste Punkt ist das was in
diesem Gesetz drin steht das eben ab
ersten ersten 24 in sieben Monaten hier
so eine komplett neue Regelung reinkommt
das ist einfach ineffizient das wird
immer dazu führen dass eben kurz vor
Schluss sich Leute noch eine fossile
Heizung erster Punkt zweiter Punkt
im Neubaugebiet wenn ich jetzt neu baue
dann ist das Haus gut gedämmt und dann
baue ich da natürlich von Anfang an die
Wärmepumpe ein ist insgesamt teurer aber
da ist das technisch auch möglich was
wir sehen ist doch dass wir eine eine
Bausubstanz auch in Deutschland haben
die die alt ist die ich nicht so einfach
umstellen kann und was derzeit passiert
ist wieder etwas ähnliches wie beim
Thema Elektromobilität eine Technologie
wird ein Schaufenster gestellt damit
gesagt das ist diejenige auf die wir auf
jeden Fall erzählen müssen die hat in
Teilen auch ihre Berechtigung aber mir
fehlt dass man es auch Techno
technologisch einfach breiter angeht
also wenn der z.B also wenn er zum
Beispiel drin steht das dass sie in in
Zukunft beim Thema Pellet also Holz das
ist da entsprechende einschränkt gibt
was ja auch irgendwie nachwachsender
Rohstoff
ist dann kann ich das beispielsweise
schlichtweg einfach nicht nachvollziehen
es geht doch noch ganz anders die
Grundfrage die auch im Raum ist und das
fragen sich ja manche auch die von
Anfang an gesagt haben wir reduzieren
wirklich unseren heizkonsum in hohem
Maße die ganz wir haben es oftmals hier
in der Bild-Zeitung sehr gekonnt hat ich
denke mal an die Waschlappen Debatte
ganz harter gegen Bild das kann
Kretschmann denn sagen die Maß der sich
an diese Forderung die Aufforderung kann
man nicht auch individuell Rücksicht
nehmen und beispielsweise weit weniger
heizen es sind viele Menschen ältere
Menschen die sagen ich werde im
Winterhalter nur noch versuchen ein
Zimmer zu heizen die gehen in ihrem
privaten Konsum heizkonsum enorm zurück
und erfüllen von daher möglicherweise
auch Dinge die andere große situierte in
ihren wunderbaren Wohnung nicht erfüllen
damit will ich sagen auch diesen
Menschen vorzuschreiben ihr müsst
gewissermaßen das halte ich in der Tat
für ein echtes Problem und das ist das
was diese Regierung die Grünen in der
Tat unterschätzt haben und den backlash
ernten sie dramatischerweise und ich
sage aber es schadet uns ein weil damit
wird diese Notwendigkeit eine
ökologische Veränderung zu machen für
möglicherweise lange Zeit gucken sich
doch an dass die SPD jetzt vorschlägt
die SPD sagt weil lasst uns das doch
2017 20 machen ja wo sind wir denn dann
wir leben doch wir werden dieses Jahr
wieder Hitze Rekorder erleben wir leben
momentan Situation in Frankreich wo ich
sag's ihm wirklich die Bauern nichts
anderes nicht mehr können als zu beten
das muss eine christliche Gottheit zur
Kenntnis nehmen ja also ich sag mal das
ist die letzte Hilfe und damit erleben
wir das wieder im Sommer also wir können
uns nicht mit immer neuem Zeit kaufen
aus dieser Situation heraus morgen auch
wenn es tatsächlich so nicht geht wie es
an wie es angesehen bin ich bei möchte
ich kein einhaken aber derer was mir
hier noch zu kurz kommt das hat der
steiniger angerissen aber bei der
Argumentation von Herr Lucke dieses
grüne
Utopia was da gezeichnet wird davon
auszugehen dass ich bin ja
Naturwissenschaftlerin und deshalb weiß
ich dass es keine Wirkung gibt ohne
Nebenwirkungen und was wir hier im
kleinen sehen mit mit den Heizung geht
ja auch im großen bei dieser
Klimapolitik muss man ja auch sehen dass
das Ganze erhebliche erhebliche
ökologische Nebenwirkungen hat die die
Windkraft Räder die die Zahl der
Windräder die wir aufstellen das ist das
ist gigantisch gigantische Flächen
werden dafür in Deutschland ähm in
Anspruch genommen die Zahl der Vögel ich
weiß nicht ob sie das ich Verf das hin
und wieder da kam die Zeit von allein
12.000 Greifvögeln die da in diesen
Windrädern zerschreddert werden die
Biomasse in Deutschland bauen wir Mais
an auf einer Fläche von der Größe
Siziliens das ist unfassbar und das das
ganze das ganze Bild was ich da ergibt
ist für mich dass das wird einfach viel
zu einseitig beschrieben also vielleicht
mal auf die Biomasse zurückzukommen
Biomasse ist ja nicht nur nicht nur Mais
ist ja auch Holz und Holz ist aus meiner
Sicht der nachhaltigste Brennstoff der
dauerhaft genutzt werden kann der
erneuerbar ist 100% erneuerbar nicht nur
65% und den faktisch zu verbieten im
Neubau das ist ja ein anderer chronismus
also da verstehe ich die Ampel überhaupt
nicht wie man so ein Gesetz überhaupt
auf dem Markt bringen kann natürlich ist
Biomasse jetzt Holz nicht mittlerweile
für alle
Gebäude das ist schon klar und das das
andere da muss ich schon auch noch mal
einhaken äh aus meiner Sicht ist es eben
ist es eben nicht so dass man sagen
sollte wenn wir jetzt die Wärmepumpe
nicht einbauen dann ist der Kipppunkt
beim Klima erreicht das ist ja auch so
einfach also ich nehme den Klimawandel
sehr sehr ernst das ist keine Frage aber
wenn man sich die Emissionsmengen
anschaut dann muss doch klar sein wir
werden jetzt mit der Wärmepumpe am 1.12
24 das Klima nicht reiten und deswegen
laufen lassen also um damit
um deine Zeit zu nennen die eindrücklich
ist wir wir imitieren durch den Aufstieg
aus der Kernkraft 15 bis 30 Millionen
Tonnen im Jahr mehr CO2 die Wärmepumpe
wird ca 20 30 10 Millionen Tonnen im
Jahr einsparen also um hier einfach mal
das Verhältnis aufzuzeigen und dafür und
dafür haben wirklich viele Menschen sehr
sehr viel Angst im Moment und bei der
Frage wie es geht wir brauchen in der
Tat Zeit und wir sehen was die Union
beispielsweise gemacht hat beim
Klimaschutzpaket 20
25 19 da hat man bei der Ölheizung
gesagt bis 26 gebe ich euch die Zeit ich
mache eine ordentliche Förderung die
jeder vorher gewusst hat mit 40 Prozent
und wenn man sich den Markt anschaut
dann hat man gesehen dass das auch
funktioniert hat dass die Leute eben
auch entsprechend gewechselt haben und
man muss sich ja auch mal die
systemische Frage stellen was passiert
denn Status Quo im Winter in der
Heizperiode zwischen November Dezember
Januar Februar dann müssen die
Kohlekraftwerke hochfahren und den Strom
entsprechend produzieren für die
Wärmepumpe also es ist nicht so eine
einfache eins zu eins Rechnung und
gleichzeitig sage ich nicht dass die
Wärmepumpe eine schlechte Technik ist
aber muss eben genau schauen wo sie
passen sieht also es ist sehr komplex
und es ist hier in dieser Runde wichtig
dass wir da alle ähm
man kann es wäre verheerend zu sagen es
gibt das Allheilmittel das ist ja
absolut das ist ja eine ganz andere
sagen würde aber ich werde auch ganz
dagegen die Möglichkeiten die wir gerade
bei Wind haben
dem einzigen der einzige Ressource fast
die uns kostenlos neben so eine Zukunft
das in der harten Auseinandersetzung die
völlig unzuträglich ist dann noch mit
Umweltschutz quasi ad actazulegen die
ganze Vogel Debatte ich erinnere nur
hier an die schönen Fensterfronten die
wir hier im Hause haben sterben und man
Vielfaches mehr tagtäglich an den
Fensterscheiben geht auch jedes Mal
unter anderem weniger hier das war eine
hat so eine wunderbare dieser ist dann
dunkel deswegen wird zu heiß aber ich
will nur sagen damit ist hier keine
Ahnung wir können uns gar nicht leisten
irgendeine der Ressourcen die wir
energetisch nachhaltig gebrauchen können
wir können es uns nicht leisten auf
irgendeine zu verzichten und deswegen
ist das Drama ich mache das gar nicht an
der Wärmepumpe fest aber sie haben
völlig recht das ist an dem Ding so zum
Nachteil der Transformation insgesamt
gereicht mit dem Absturz der Grünen ist
für uns alle eine Frage bin ich völlig
bei ihnen es geht ja auch gar nicht um
verzichten aber ich wünsche mir dann
doch das ganze erstens ausgewogen dass
sie diskutieren und zweitens auch alles
etwas
ausgewogener abzustimmen die Mischung
recht da gebe ich Ihnen recht sonst
hätte wahrscheinlich auf die
Konzentration nur auf die Wärmepumpe
nicht gehabt man hätte nicht diese die
Angriffsfläche wäre verringert worden
wenn man gesagt hätte wir haben eine
Breite der Möglichkeiten dass ich genau
genommen
sachlicher nicht mit so viel Angst nicht
mit so viel wert wie so ein bisschen die
Absolution es muss jetzt schnell sonst
passiert das große Unglück fehlt ihm das
in der Debatte das schlimmste ist doch
wenn sie ihn Probleme haben und über
emotional an dieses Problem rangehen das
machen ja die klimakleber hier in Berlin
die irgendwie Angst und Schrecken und
Untergangsszenario haben sie müssen
vernünftig rational an dieses Problem
dran gehen das heißt ich bin schon der
Auffassung wir müssen jede Stellschraube
an in der Energieerzeugung drehen die
haben Wind Sonne Kernkraft auch das
Thema Gas LNG und anderes und
gleichzeitig aber nicht dann auf eine
Technologie im Verbrauch setzen das
haben wir auf der einen Seite beim Thema
Elektromobilität gesehen und jetzt auch
hier beim Thema Wärmepumpe und das
Problem der Diskussion der letzten drei
Monate ist doch das jetzt in großen
Teilen der Bevölkerung im Grunde und
diese Technologie kaputt ist weil jeder
denkt was wollen wir denn mit dieser
Wärmepumpe und ich für meinen Teil habe
wenn ich draußen in der Bevölkerung
unterwegs bin schon das Gefühl da braut
sich gerade etwas zusammen wir haben die
Umfragen aus Ostdeutschland wo wir sehen
dass im Grunde genommen
der Sonntagsfrage mit 26% unglaublich
und und das liegt natürlich auch an
dieser Angst an dieser Sorge und wenn
ich dann jemand wir werden ja heute auch
den Staatssekretär reichen noch noch zu
sprechen kommen der vor wenigen Tagen in
einem Interview im auf was man auf
Youtube nachschauen kann sagt naja die
Industrie den dann halt die Patient
fehlen für die dann die Energie zu teuer
die werden dann halt abwandern aber dann
ist das halt so so und und und so geht's
halt nicht aus meiner Sicht wenn man
verantwortungsvolle Politik machen
möchte
Preis zahlen dass eben auch Industrien
abwandern Herr von dunkel das eben auch
ein Wohlstandsverlust für alle für eine
breite Bevölkerung damit einhergeht ist
das der Preis den man sich bewusst
machen muss anders wird es nicht genau
wir werden manche Industrie vielleicht
wirklich verlieren aber es wird eben ein
anderes Modell auch von Wohlstand zum
Teil sein müssen wir werden uns bewusst
machen dass manche Dinge vielleicht auch
einfach nicht mehr gehen ganz einfach
also mal ganz ganz hart gesprochen die
Debatte um die Frage von CO2 Bepreisung
auch die Debatte um die Frage wie hoch
müssen Preise sein beispielsweise ein
Thema wie Privatflugzeuge denken wir mal
beispielsweise an an die Niederlande und
mittlerweile Flughäfen einfach sagen wir
akzeptieren Privatflugzeuge mit da sind
es auch Bereiche von Konsum die
irgendwann eine Debatte hervorrufen
werden was ist noch zuträglich und ähm
betrifft quasi nur den Bereich der
Menschen die privat fliegen oder glauben
Sie es geht so weit dass man irgendwann
sagen muss selbst das normale
ich sage Ihnen ganz konkret das wird
richtig hart und es liegt daran dass wir
natürlich gucken Sie doch an wir haben
immer noch eine Privilegierung des
Kerosins wir subventionieren Rosinen wir
machen die Preise für die billige
Mallorca reisen die natürlich und das
ist das harte momentan Menschen die sich
vieles nicht leisten können ermöglicht
sogar nach Mallorca zu fliegen wenn wir
das eines Tages zu dem Preis käuflich
machen der ist eigentlich sein müsste in
dem nicht der Preis die ökologische
Wahrheit sagt werden wir vieles faktisch
unterbinden das ist eine ungeheuer seine
ungeheuerliche und da wird es richtig
brutal da wird mich dann wirklich der
Konfliktstoff da deswegen glaube ich
trauen sich manche das ist auch eine
Anfrage an die die besser situiert sind
sie trauen sich vielleicht nicht
ehrlicherweise zu sagen ja wir werden
natürlich auch für uns ein Bus nehmen
das sind Gerechtigkeit Fragen die sind
so immens weil wir momentan ein Land
natürlich haben und da geht's zum Kern
die haben uns in der Breite an einen
Wohlstand Level gewöhnt wo auch zum
Beispiel Leute die wirklich nicht viel
haben sich das leisten können die noch
in Urlaub auf Mallorca interessant oder
in der Türkei manchmal sogar leichter
leichter bezahlen können also ich fliege
nicht mehr ich fliege nicht mehr weil
ich fliege schon noch mal aber weißt du
konkretes Beispiel ja oder nein
ich habe mir ich darf schon schlechtes
Gewissen hauptsache ich ganz ehrlich das
sage ich ganz ehrlich und die hat damals
geguckt fährst du mit dem Zug jetzt
zukünftig weil einfach der Zug da fährst
seit zwei Tagen ist unterwegs aber
beispielsweise Presseclub oder so Unfug
Entschuldigung also nicht als Unfall mit
dem Fliegen meine ich war gerade wieder
da es hat mir Spaß gemacht und ich fahre
gerne immer ich fahre natürlich nur zu
alle ich will bei all diesen
Inlandsflügen die Frage aufwerfen ist
die Zeitersparnis für jemanden die man
von einem kleinen komfortablen Problem
der Zeit also alles aber sie leben so
dass sie sagen ich fliege jetzt nicht
mehr in Urlaub ich esse dein Fleisch
mehr das ist der Preis immer sehr genau
unterhalten ob das Fleisch er sich z.B
ich bin mache mich nicht zum Heiligen
bin ich der letzte ich esse ich esse
liebend gerne eine Wurst ich esse auch
gerne da kann ich gar nicht behaupten
dass ich so konsequent wäre würde ich
nicht nein ich respektiere
gehabt ich wohne in Berlin deswegen ich
habe wirklich ernst gehabt ich habe das
Glück gehabt
der Diskussion die wir haben eben man
spricht sich ja wenn man wo ist
ist ja das was sie auch ansprechen weil
spricht sich in Berlin einfach leichter
als wenn man auf dem platten Platten
die ja durchaus Sinn ergibt also man
muss nicht 15 Mal im Jahr nach Mallorca
fliegen aber wenn es dann soweit geht
dass man gar nicht mehr in den Urlaub
fliegen kann dann wird es natürlich
schon auch zur sozialen Frage und das
andere ist wenn wir dann eine
Bevölkerungsschicht haben die sich das
Haus gedämmt hinstellt und die
Wärmepumpe einbaut und sich dann
moralisch überlegen fühlt der Frau die
entsprechenden Ölofen Spaß am liebt dann
haben wir in diesen Problemen und
insofern insofern ist die Debatte noch
mal wenn man es an der Wärmepumpe fest
macht also sowas von dermaßen verfehlt
und auch daneben das muss eigentlich gar
nicht in Worte fassen kann wenn da beim
Förderkonzept beispielsweise
vorgeschlagen wird das dann die über 80
jährigen ja einen Sprinter Bonus
bekommen von
über 50% Förderung bei einer Investition
von über 40.000 Euro dann kennt man eben
die Lebenssituation doch nicht also es
ist ja nicht so dass wir alle im
Wohlstand leben
genau
dass man mit dem Geld dass man hat über
die Runden kommt und da ist es dann
jetzt schon die soziale Frage die eben
auch wirklich Angst macht den Leuten und
es wird an vielen Beispielen festgemacht
und da ist es eine natürlich die Frage
des guten Lebens aber wenn es konkret
wird dann geht's eben auch um
Wohlstandsverluste und dann hat man
vergleicht sich ja nicht nur in
Deutschland weil vergleicht sich ja dann
auch mit den mit den Nachbarn auf in
Europa aber dann auch drüber hinaus und
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass wir das
richtige nur richtig machen können wenn
es auch entsprechend akzeptiert wird in
der in der Bevölkerung und deswegen noch
mal wenn man es ihm beim Beispiel der
Wärmepumpe fest macht da ist eigentlich
alles falsch gemacht worden was man so
falsch machen kann und da ist das Kind
auch schon in den Brunnen gefallen und
ich hoffe ich hoffe wirklich dass es
nicht bei anderen Bereichen
sofortgesetzt wird weil ansonsten ist es
ja nicht die Spaltung zwischen
klimaaktivisten oder diesen klimaklebern
der Gesellschaft entsprechend da
entstehen wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall